Good old shepherd Smith on Fox News just shredded
Donald Trump yesterday saying
quite simply, Trump is not telling you the
truth.
And of course Trump is furious over this and
is now saying it's time for Republicans and
right-wingers to move on from Fox News to
something else.
I've been predicting that.
I'll talk to you about that a little bit later
on today.
Donald Trump, of course, as I told you earlier
on in the show, panicking about the border
wall.
I told you earlier, he is now telling officials,
break the law, do whatever you need to do.
Start seizing land, appropriating funds, build
the damn wall.
And I will pardon you.
He's also lying by saying he's building the
wall, which is simply not true.
So in this clip that I'm going to show you
some excerpts of Shep Smith is doing multiple
fact checks.
He is one of the few sort of occasional voices
of reason on Fox News.
It's no big accomplishment.
It's no big praise.
It's merely listen, every once in awhile,
Shep Smith and sometimes Chris Wallace and
one time, uh, Neil Kabuto just tell the truth
on Fox News.
And it's notable because it's so infrequent
that it takes place.
Here is Shep Smith starting to just very clearly
say what Donald Trump is telling you is not
true.
As Dorian appears ready to skirt by the American
territory of Puerto Rico, if not hit somewhere
around San Juan.
President Trump is calling the island one
of the most corrupt places on earth.
He added that.
By the way, he's the best thing that ever
happened to Puerto Rico.
Those clearly are opinions as opposed to facts.
So there's something actually brilliant about
this that I want to talk about.
Shep Smith is sort of being snarky by saying
this is an opinion and not a fact.
Like in the ideal world, people would understand
that when you look at a tweet from the president,
this is the perspective.
This is the point of view.
This is the opinion of the president.
That's it.
It might contain accuracies, it might contain
inaccuracies, but it's not just snark on Fox
News.
It's actually extremely relevant that Shepard
Smith is saying that's an opinion and not
a fact because this is Fox News and we have
to think about the Fox News audience and that
this is a Fox News anchor.
Fox News has made a business out of blurring
the lines between news and opinion.
We've talked many times about this.
Fox News will often stand behind this idea
that we may have a right wing bent on our
opinion programs, but our news programming
is just news.
And of course there is no just news programming
on Fox News that is not ideologically right
wing and they are notorious for deliberately
confusing.
It's low information audience about what is
unused report and what is an opinion.
And can you tell from the way it looks, can
you tell from the language that's being used,
how is it that you can tell?
The whole point of Fox News is they blur the
lines so that their audience can't tell the
difference.
So to you and me, when Shep Smith says this
is an opinion, not a fact, we see it as kind
of being clever or snarky or making a joke.
There are tons of people in Fox News as audience
that do not understand the difference between
news and opinion.
And they believe that everything Fox News
says is simply reporting a fact.
They believe that everything Donald Trump
tweets is a fact.
So it's actually very clever of Shep Smith
to point this out because of the Fox News
audience audience on any other channel that
would be like, yeah, we know that.
Uh, let's continue.
The president also repeating his false claim
about the aid that Puerto Rico received.
Here's this tweet from yesterday.
Wow.
Yet another big storm heading to Puerto Rico.
Will it ever end?
Congress approved $92 billion from Puerto
Rico last year and all time record of its
kind for anywhere.
That is decidedly not true.
We checked with sources including the Federal
Emergency Management Agency or FEMA, and the
latest numbers show that as of the end of
June, the federal government has allocated
42.7 billion from Puerto Rico.
Shep Smith has to talk like a teacher talks
to a first grader.
Do you know the difference between a lie and
the truth?
This is an example of something that is not
true.
It's truly amazing that whenever a Fox News
host has to stop the disinformation narratives
that they perpetuate, suddenly they have to
talk like they're speaking to a child or I
guess to an adult that's severely cognitively
or ideologically limited.
Uh Okay.
And then on to the actual part about the wall
an hour ago he tweeted that the wall is going
up very fast despite obstruction by Democrats
and today the Washington Post reports the
president is telling his age to use quotes,
imminent domain to seize private land and
ignore environmental laws and that he told
senior aids that if he doesn't get it done
it would be embarrassing.
And when staffers explained that some of his
requests would require them to break the law,
the paper reports, he responded that if anybody
gets in trouble quote, don't worry I'll pardon
you.
The post reports, one official told the Washington
Post that the president was joking and just
moments ago the president tweeted that the
report is as he put it fake news.
But the president also said in the tweet that
the wall is going up rapidly.
It is not as we just reported.
There is no new wall.
Once again, Shep Smith has to explain to his
viewers as if they are just little kids in
the most basic terms and the most basic language
possible.
In some sense, I'm kind of imagining being
foxed Nate at Fox and you being chef Smith
on Fox News.
It must be frustrating if you're Shep Smith
to realize that if you want to communicate
truth to your viewers, if you want to puncture
the echo chamber in which your viewers mostly
live, you have to do the news equivalent of
baby talk.
Uh, in any case, good for Shep. Trump seems
to be abandoning Fox News anyway and maybe
his supporters will will as well.
I want to talk about that next because this
is a story that I predicted months ago and
it's continuing to grow.